hi i'm kristen goodwin on this episode
of the fox news rundown
presumptive democratic presidential
nominee joe biden choosing former rival
california senator kamala harris to be
his running mate
making her the first black woman and
first south asian american woman on a
major party ticket
but will biden's pick prompt president
trump to change his re-election strategy
trump 2020 national press secretary
hogan gidley weighs in on this
and shares his insights on the democrats
selection
and for nearly 25 years nancy grace has
been on television discussing crime
and fighting for victims rights the
former prosecutor has a new fox nation
special
called american kidnapping finding
elizabeth smart with nancy grace
she joins the rundown to discuss what
she's learned about the smart case
and shares her thoughts on the
allegations against jeffrey epstein's
former associate galene maxwell
plus commentary by washington times
opinion editor and fox news contributor
charlie hurt
the fox news rundown is a daily news
podcast where we
take a deeper look at the stories
important to you you can subscribe on
your favorite podcast player
by going to foxnewspodcast.com i'm jason
chaffetz
i'm katie pavlich i'm steve doocy and
this is the fox news rundown
wednesday august 12th 2020 i'm lisa
brady
the new biden harris team isn't changing
the focus for the trump campaign
which wants voters tuned to the top of
the ticket
they can see a charlatan from a mile
away and that's what joe biden is and so
we're going to remind the american
people just how far left joe biden
has gotten i'm chris foster nancy grace
takes a new look at elizabeth smart's
kidnapping 18 years ago
it gets me so distraught but the more we
look at the crime and the more we look
at the way it happened
we find out more and more and more
details and i'm charlie hurt i've got
the final word on the fox news rundown
[Music]
joe biden didn't just pick a running
mate the presumptive democratic nominee
made history california senator kamala
harris about to become the first black
woman
or south asian on a major party's
presidential ticket
months after ending her own run for
president fellow senator and former
candidate amy klobuchar telling fox's
bret baer
i'm so happy for her and she will be a
great running mate because
she's got the experience to serve as
vice president
to work side by side with joe biden to
have people's back she has
she ran literally the biggest justice
department in the country
next to the department of justice harris
was california's attorney general and a
prosecutor before running for senate
biden calls her a fearless fighter for
the little guy and one of the country's
finest public servants
and harris says biden can unify the
american people
but she had a viral moment during an nbc
debate at his expense
do you agree today that you were wrong
to oppose
bussing in america then do you agree i
did not oppose busing in america what i
opposed
is busing ordered by the department of
education
challenging biden's record on civil
rights she said things during the
debates during the
democrat primary debates that were
horrible about
sleepy joe president trump says he's
surprised by the choice
she was very disrespectful to joe biden
and it's hard to pick somebody that's
that disrespectful
the trump campaign calls her phony
kamala
and part of a joe biden surrender to a
radical mob
well people vote for the top of the
ticket and
poll after poll shows that hogan gidley
is national press secretary for the
trump campaign
what's interesting about joe biden is he
is an empty vessel
and sooner or later empty vessels have
to be filled by
something and in this particular
instance joe biden's
move to the radical socialist left is
finally complete
he has been embracing these radical
ideas of
government takeover of health care the
green new deal
you know defunding the police
restructuring
law enforcement those are things he's
been talking about
and and has finally embraced him in this
pick with kamala harris
that being said as i mentioned at the
beginning it's still
all about joe biden he's the one at the
top of the ticket
which should be noted though is that joe
biden also has mentioned he's a
transitional candidate
so there's no guarantee he's going to
run for a second term
meaning he has selected someone
from this radical base and chances are
um you know he's going to govern that
way i mean
the the democrat party has moved so far
left
and while joe biden may be the face it's
the kamala harrises of the world
who are the heart of this radical
movement and so
they are clearly two peas in a pod and
it looks like they're going to run
a radically left campaign on
radically left issues to try and remake
this country into the image of a
socialist nation they've been pretty
open and obvious about it so we'll see
where it goes from here
kamala harris though has actually faced
some criticism
from the left for being too tough on
crime when she was attorney general
so does picking her help to counter
president trump's message that biden
is beholden to the radical left and not
tough enough amid you know the unrest in
american cities
well it's interesting you mentioned that
because she also used that office to
inflate
her conviction rate too and so two
things can be true at once
she may have tried to inflate
her toughness back then but now where we
are
and the radical moves of the left proves
that
you know she's just phony and what she's
trying to say now is we should defund
the police and we should restructure law
enforcement
uh take a look at that so it's pretty
clear
her move uh to embrace radical leftist
ideology is now complete as well and so
that's where the democrat party's base
is that's where they're going to try and
move
and you know typically in campaigns
what's so interesting is
you run to the far reaches of your
party to try and win and secure the
nomination then you work to moderate
here it's almost been the exact opposite
joe biden tried to pretend as though he
was a moderate
during the primary now he has braced
embraced rather
the full-on radical agenda of the left
and so
someone like kamala harris who is going
to try
and sell the american people
she's somehow tough on crime when in
fact she's the one who
wants um you know to to allow the the
defunding of the police
and uh you know putting our our american
people in our communities and our
citizenry
at at risk that's going to be a tough
sell
though biden keeps saying he's not for
defunding police he's said that numerous
times he keeps saying it
um well yeah but here but hold on
there's a big difference there because
what he says is when he was asked
can't we all agree we need to redirect
funding
he said yes absolutely and if you don't
think redirect
is the same thing as defund then i'd
like to redirect your next paycheck into
my bank account
it's all the same thing the semantic
games the press are trying to do to
cover
for joe biden's record to cover for joe
biden's misstatements to cover for joe
biden's
massive embrace of the leftist policies
it's not going to work the american
people see through that um
they can you know they they they can see
a charlatan from a mile away and that's
what joe biden is and so
we're going to remind the american
people uh just how far left joe biden
has has gotten the president has been
predicting
a big rebound in the third quarter
report just before election day on the
economy
what if that report right before
election day
is not good or not as good as he's
hoping it'll be
well i don't want to get into
hypotheticals but let but while we
while we do play the hypothetical game
let me do that as we're coming out of
coronavirus
and trying to get this country back on
track economically the last
three months consecutive months
have been the largest job gains in the
history of this country
and our president who rebuilt this
economy once
we can is rebuilding it again
and what's interesting about your
question is
as we play the hypothetical game what if
joe biden were to get elected
as we're trying to rebound out of
coronavirus
with a plan to increase taxes
by four trillion dollars on the american
people
by granting amnesty to more than 11
million
illegal aliens flooding the job market
preventing americans from getting jobs
first
as the jobs start to come back and i
always like to say
you don't have to guess how an economy
would look under these two men you've
seen it
three years under um president donald
trump
half a million manufacturing jobs coming
back into this country
more jobs and there were people to fill
them uh
incredible trade deals that protected
the american worker
cutting taxes deregulation and we saw
joe biden's economy for eight years too
sixty thousand manufacturing plants
closed three and a half million jobs
leaving american citizens going directly
to china
850 000 jobs gone because of his
horrible nafta deal
so when you look at the comparison my
understanding of
real numbers real data and real jobs is
real clear
and that is if this president is not
reelected the market will crash and the
jobs will be gone because we've seen
that already
under joe biden how concerned are you
though about
who might take the blame from voters for
lack of agreement on another
big coronavirus relief package
well you know it's it's um it's pretty
clear right now
that if congress is going to continue to
play politics with people's lives
then the president is going to do what's
right to ensure the american people have
money
in their pockets to pay rent to put food
in their stomachs and clothes on their
kids backs he's done it before he'll do
it again
and this isn't the first time nancy
pelosi has blown up
a deal to protect the american people
she did this early on in the coronavirus
pandemic in which there was a deal
struck between the white house and the
in the senate i was at the white house
at the time
and then nancy pelosi came in and said
no i want to tack on all of my green new
deal socialist agenda items
that's why you see the word cannabis in
these deals more than you see the word
jobs
the american people understand when this
president stepped to the podium
and said we're going to now make sure
with an executive order
that i'm going to move funding around so
that you can have
the necessary money needed to continue
to live your lives to continue your
well-being and then the democrats
response is i'm going to sue the federal
government to make sure the american
people don't get that money
if you want to be on that side of the
democrats be my guest but the american
people are going to understand and know
that it was donald trump who was looking
out for their future and not the
democrats
the conventions are finally upon us um
not looking
anything like they would have been
planned to look like thanks to the
pandemic
how much does that matter that you're
not having all the big rallies and that
it isn't going to be a normal convention
either
um it does matter uh because you know i
think the american people
um you know they expect to see their
candidates out there
you know being pressure tested by the
mainstream media
taking tough tough you know tough
incoming uh
talking to the american people letting
them ask tough questions as well
and we're not seeing that because of
covet as you mentioned this quarantine
these
these shutdowns um the virus is still
here in many ways and so
conventional campaigning isn't a thing
right now
uh so one of the one of the issues of
the campaign we've tried to do is make
sure our online presence
is is you know second to none is the
envy of the political world and that has
actually happened and that's a
that's a good thing so it's pretty clear
that um all of the momentum the
excitement's on our side and so
without that um you know you would also
expect the american people to see these
debates those are upcoming
one of the issues we've had with that is
the schedule so late it's a 1980s
schedule for a 2020 election and so by
the time the first debate happens
you're looking at eight million people
with the potential of voting in
16 states we want to move that debate up
so that the people can get a chance to
see these two men
outlining their visions for the future
of this country side by side and we
firmly believe the uplifting unifying
patriotic message of this president
america first uh america one for all
compared to joe biden's america last
and and you know crazy socialist ideas
you know placating to china that's going
to be a problem for them
but if we're not going to see that
debate you know at that time it's still
okay because as i mentioned the campaign
apparatus we've built here
is so massive and so ready and so
energized
this vp pick quite frankly energizes us
even more and we're excited to move
forward
trump campaign national press secretary
hogan gidley
thanks very much for your time thanks so
much have a great day
[Applause]
[Music]
this is charlie hurt with your fox news
commentary coming up
nancy grace has been doing what she does
on tv since 1996
talking about crime analyzing cases and
fighting for victims rights
she was a prosecutor in atlanta before
that handling sometimes violent crimes
saying she was drawn to that career
because of her fiance's murder in 1979
her new documentary on fox nation is
called american kidnapping
finding elizabeth smart this is jeff
ross he's with the fba
detective get me behind me satan
i'm not satan and i'm right here that's
salt lake city police detective courtney
parks interrogating the man now in
prison for life for the kidnapping brian
david mitchell
nancy grace spent a lot of time covering
the elizabeth smart kidnapping
i remember elizabeth smart's kidnapping
like it was yesterday
the shot now at that time i didn't have
children
now i do and it makes it even more
difficult for me to
take in the thinking
of someone who would invade your home
in the middle of the night in order to
steal
your child that the thinking is
not that any of them are good but when
your child
is you know walking around a mall
without you there
and or around a playground or they're
they're biking or hiking
and they're kind of out there in the
public
where people can see them that's bad
enough but to think someone
would sneak into your home while you're
lying
in bed asleep you know physically just
you know 30 feet away from them
and take your child i remember
how fantastical it was and in cases
where children
go missing from home of course the first
place you look
is that the parents but when i looked
at elizabeth's parents no way
when i listened to them no way they were
the pain was just so apparent
when i looked at them their words were
so
oh it just hurts to hear how much
they were hurting and so that left me
trying to figure out and analyze
the clues left behind well and of course
these
every parent's worst nightmare kind of
kidnappings are exceedingly rare uh
not i mean from a home of course but
even from a mall
or whatever so of course you start with
the parents and then you broaden your
circle
out to you know exes or
friends neighbors people who may have
done work in the home uh who ended up
doing this of course it was had nothing
to do with the smarts as i suspected
after i first heard them begging for her
return
it was brian mitchell and his crackpot
wife wanda barzee may they both
rot in hell did he
just refresh my memory it's been a while
the mom
thinking she was doing a good deed
brought in a day laborer that's right to
to pay him for work on the home to try
to give somebody
a helping hand that needed a job
so she brings mitchell in to do some
work at the house
he sees a house he sees elizabeth
and it's a done deal he targets her
and comes after her and gets her
i remember very well also being in the
newsroom
the morning it was announced that she
was found and you don't get that very
often
no and it hurts me to say that
like i cover on
fox nation and sirius
and our podcast oh oh gosh i can't even
tell you how many times a week
a missing child and
as i'm reporting it i'm begging people
to
call in tips to help find the child
but i know in the back of my mind
there's not going to be a good outcome
and i i i hate it and i always believe
you're going gonna laugh i always
believed the other night i started
crying
and my husband said what's wrong and i
said this little girl
has been found dead and he said did you
think there was a chance she would be
found alive i went
yeah i did i always think there's a
chance they're going to be found alive
so you're right again statistically
when a child is taken by a stranger
there's usually not a good outcome
elizabeth smart story in the storyboard
kidnapping
i assumed had been pretty well told
what's new in this documentary
oh you know what the well number one
wanda barzee has walked free
yes she's free she was released
and it just it gets me so distraught
but the more we look at the crime
and the more we look at the way it
happened
we find out more and more and more
details now let me just say praise god
and i know in the media business they
don't like to hear that kind of thing
but i'm just saying praise
god elizabeth was found alive
and she has gone on with her life but
you know as a crime victim myself
people use the word closure or go
on with their life and yes we do
but i always say there's no such thing
as closure
because the violent crime affects you
the rest
of your life you i always
say it's like you break your arm and
you never get it set but you learn to
make a pancake
it's not the same way you can't flip it
in the air you go on with your life
but you're never the same
so we learn a lot as time goes by
about elizabeth about the effect it's
had on her
and her family and in my mind
justice has been denied because wanda
barzee has walked free
what do you think of her what was her
relationship with mitchell
was she any kind of a victim or was she
just as guilty as him
she's just as guilty as him and yes
she may be have she may have been afraid
of him
but that does not excuse what happened
to elizabeth and her
role in it they were out in public
at times with elizabeth all she would
have to do is ask for help
but she stood by and let elizabeth be
brutalized
for months just treated
worse than bad people would treat an
animal
and this beautiful girl was mistreated
and
wanda barzee stood by and let it happen
and
even aided abetted encouraged
yes she's guilty speaking of women in
general who are
accused of aiding and abetting horrible
acts uh you have this
it was the smart special on fox nation
you also have a colleen maxwell special
on fox nation that isn't too old
uh we can just talk about that for a
minute do you think she's gonna sing do
you think she's gonna sing prosecutors
have all the leverage here what does she
gain from not talking and spending maybe
her life in prison you know what
the way you phrase that question you're
absolutely right
she is going to give up evidence
although let's think about it for a
minute what does she really have
yes i know she's got a lot but
let's think this through if she's
claiming to have videos and photos
of wealthy powerful or influential
people having
sex relations with minors
it's my understanding that when
epstein's manhattan townhome was raided
they found a lot of that in his safe
or somewhere on the premises if they've
already got that
what can she really give them i mean
she'd have to give me a lot before i cut
her a deal
i i'm telling you but do i think she
will yes
yes i think they've got the goods on her
because of the victims they're speaking
out
and they're totally implicating her as
recruiting them schooling them grooming
them even taking part
in their molestation that's sick she
needs to go to jail
and stay in jail she doesn't need to see
the light of day
and i really can't believe she's whining
about her conditions behind bars because
the girls that were molested
have been sentenced to a lifetime of
remembering
the molestations that aside yes
i think she'll give information and that
darn well better be good
for the feds to cut a deal with her yes
i think she's implicated
because so many victims have implicated
her not just one
it's not just one person's word against
her word it's several
what are they all lying in order to
frame a woman they've never met
i don't think so but there's no
description like a first-hand
description
so let's just see what miss maxwell is
going to give up before we
rush to cut a deal with the devil well
and we're only talking about her because
of all the money and the luxury involved
we're not talking about her if she's
the girlfriend of some poor guy we've
never heard of
who i do who i don't know about you but
i do
well of course we aren't we well that's
your job i mean the public doesn't know
um job it's my calling
and i it means a lot to me that we
represent all crime victims but i have
to agree with you yet again
i think a lot of the fascination with
gillan maxwell
is her wealth her pedigree
her education um
because you're right and the public is
right
it's an aberration you don't normally
see
a sophisticated highbrow well-educated
millionaire female of all things in that
scenario
charged with sex trafficking of children
yeah that doesn't pop up every day
you're right about that again
man you're scoring 100 on this test i
think and it's just like
why why because she has
everything that everybody else seems to
want you know the money
the connections the home the clothes the
parties
blah blah blah why would she do this
i don't you know what i think i think
it's because she
loved epstein she wanted epstein
in her life and this is what she did to
make that happen
nancy grace um here with us in the fox
family on fox nation her
latest documentary american kidnapping
is elizabeth smart story there's a
director's cut of there on fox nation
now nancy was good talking to you thanks
thank you so much
bye friend
[Music]
getting schooled is a podcast hosted by
fox nation's abby hornacek
each week abby and her expert guests
tackle topics we take for granted and
help explain the roots and meanings
behind them subscribe and listen now by
going to foxnewspodcasts.com
america is listening to fox news read
and review the fox news rundown on apple
podcasts or wherever you listen
it's time for your fox news commentary
charlie
hurt what's on your mind defund city
police departments
exploding murder rates free health care
for illegal aliens
crushing debt obliterate american
history
for democrat politicians the era of
american exceptionalism is over
welcome to the land of shelter in place
the fear-mongering and democracy is
enough to choke a mule
at least it would choke the mule that
symbolized the old democrat party
even the democrat party of just a few
elections ago
these people today they've gone plum mad
the inmates have taken siege of the
asylum
senator maisie hirono hawaii democrat
stormed out of a committee hearing
rather than denounce
the fascist domestic terrorist group
calling itself antifa
the loose knit violent mob has been
implicated in firebombing police
stations
and federal buildings attacking peace
officers including blinding
four cops with laser pointers and
violently assaulting
innocent citizens yet democrats such as
house judiciary committee chairman
gerald nadler dismissed the mayhem
caused by these anti-american terrorists
as a myth
despite reels and reels of video
evidence
mr nadler is the highest ranking house
democrat on matters of the judiciary
ms hirono is on the actual committee
that chooses
federal judges the very black robed men
and women who met out
life and death decisions for regular
taxpaying citizens of this country
so much for equal justice under law or
justice
in any form other than mob justice
terrifying
but this is what happens when an entire
party is hijacked by fascist mobs who
govern by twitter
they blot out any dissent first on
social media
then in the streets where their
preferred weapons are brass knuckles
ropes and molotov cocktails the only
response from democrat paul's in
washington
is to condemn law enforcement accuse
police of being the fascists
remember president obama remember 2008
that was a different time a different
campaign
it was hopeful he at least pretended to
love america
he denounced divisions between red
america and blue america
not that he governed like that but at
least he was wise enough to know he
could never get elected peddling any of
the crazy nonsense
these democrats today are slopping out
that is why president obama chose to be
joe biden's political protege in the
2008 campaign
but poor joe biden today he is either
too dumb
or too out of it to realize what his
party has become
again barack obama would never have run
on a platform like this
but forever leading from behind mr obama
endorsed his
first wave of democrats running in new
york this year
among those mr obama hilariously
endorsed
is jamal bowman a socialist
community organizer who already beat
long time sitting democrat
congressman elliott engel for the
democrat nomination over three weeks ago
talk about leading from behind among
those mr obama did not
include in his list of endorsements was
sitting congressperson
alexandria ocasio-cortez the freshman
member of congress who was leading her
party's circus off the cliff
into the arms of antifa maybe mr obama
worries that mrs
ocasio-cortez is too radical for his
brand of politics
or maybe he's just jealous
charlie hurt washington times
you've been listening to the fox news
rundown stay up to date by subscribing
to this podcast at foxnewspodcasts.com
and for up to the minute news go to
foxnews.com
love fox news click the subscribe button
to get more of the news and opinion you
trust
and click the fox news rundown playlist
for the latest episodes